Nina tells Brindisi so far make lemonade
from lemons that's that's the plan for
today not quite the reaction I want from
the wife you she's like oh my god the
best thing ever
[Music]
okay believe nation welcome to day three
of our European trip we had a pretty
solid rest last night or get another
cabinet 11 o'clock
good job Nina we're gonna have it to
breakfast
how you feeling good still tired today
we're gonna be in bring DC we're still
on the boat but we're on our way to
bring the sea gonna get some food Tina's
gonna go back to the cabinet nap and
then we're gonna explore in DC
[Music]
okay we got the leftovers before they
closed everything up
there everything is all closed and they
prepare for lunch so we got some
cappuccino some weird egg thing I don't
know what that is
some weird super fan more eggs
Ashford's image Everdeen how is it Nina
life is back what did you get
it's lunch time
how is it
it's open inna go get your lunch oh
that's a pretty light looking lunch
sausage four pieces of pasta I love it
no that's the whole point of having a
buffet you take what you want on that
plate what are you most excited by
I'm just okay I'm almost done my coffee
time come here to get some food okay
here's mine bocconcini pizza pasta
burgers doing the whole low-carb thing
[Music]
okay time to get off the boat we're
going to breed DC which is a little
Italian town on the cruise ship
itinerary they say it's not not a lot
that you can do here not a not a full
day so we'll see the disappointing news
is that all the seafood places that I
picked up for me in our all closed until
Tuesday it's Monday today I don't know
why they're closed on Monday there is a
special holiday or something but I'm not
happy about that you got to find a
back-up plan
better get some Nina some food so I've
got some options we'll see how it goes
and right now just get off the boat and
take our stairs okay we are waiting to
get off
so far so instead of a midlife
frustrated
we're gonna do drinks I'm going with my
after eight drink again
I gotta mix it up because all of the all
the mint there's at the bottom Annina
got what is that caramel latte
that looks YUM
thank good nice
[Music]
Nina helps Brindisi so far hot
damn hot real hot
so on top of it being a really small
city and not what you do in the first
place for some reason most of the things
are closed either Mondays we're day for
them or it's a holiday
usually Sundays and everybody's closed
so we're just going to make the best of
it make the best of it make lemonade
from lemons that's that's the plan for
today lemonade from lemons lemonade
first stop famous coffee shop and not
sweets pastry shop that fake continental
yeah something's open Nina you ready for
some pastries and coffee we've had how
much coffee today I've had I've had
three all right so we got our table we
got four pastries
and two coffees coming and pistachio I
think that's lemon or vanilla I don't
remember what that was and this is
pineapple which one looks most
interesting to you Nina try the try the
cannoli we haven't had a cannoli yet in
Italy their last Italy stop pistachio
cannoli all right so we're giving it a
upper medium it's enough all right yes
husband hits a home run again maybe
let's call it a triple maybe not a home
run I'm giving myself a triple on this
one oh not quite the reaction I want
from the wife you she's like oh my cause
the best thing ever
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay we have arrived at the restaurant
to try to get Nina some yummy seafood
yeah Betty cafe don't let us down
don't let his stand I mean I got some
white wine
looks like the glass is dirty she's not
happy with it and I got I got Italian
beer Peroni okay Cheers
all right here we go mussels and seafood
pasta hmm okay
moment of truth this is it Nina this is
it
get a shrimp oh my goodness the fingers
are massively crossed right now there it
is and which ways the thumb going that's
it okay and okay
Pass pass is good muscles not good Nina
want to change your statement the other
ones are good
it's thumbs up or just medium yeah Thank
You Brenda see alright gotta head back
to the boat we've got 15 minutes or so
20 minutes to get back bad this was a
quality meal I'm feeling good full
satisfied get back on the boat eat
dinner we're gonna doing the boat get
back on the boat and relax and shower
and shower and then eat dinner yes it
was a small city but the cafe was decent
and in this place saved it for us
I didn't see
[Music]
milkshake time for Evan milkshake time
for Evan
it's the yummiest milkshake but mom one
that goes in my mouth the cheek time I
could be a jingle like a death to be
jingle was it yeah we're gonna go
smoothie instead tropical delight
coconut ice cream with yogurt fresh
mango banana and pineapple name is gonna
get the tropical spritz passion fruits
here and after all we're second club
soda
all right let's order
[Music]
okay.we what do we do we relaxed we both
had showers I changed my shirt to
something fancy much more fancy the
other one right super fence is my fancy
wear and we're off to dinner thing are
you hungry
not really me neither so let's go eat
because that's how we do on cruise ships
how was it we got some grilled calamari
oh and shrimp
I look I was slightly down the entrees
here I have clam sauce spaghetti
Annina has what kind of result though
seafood vegetarian risotto okay
senior I give it a shot last one was was
here
so like this we're staking the here
alright a little bit better than the
other phase here right I like it
dessert time cinnamon rice pudding and
vanilla ice cream all me Nina doesn't
have a sweet tooth it's so windy my hair
is everywhere this is romantic it's
romantic look
all right I got my decaf cappucino and
it's got her two glasses of wine we're
gonna head back to the room relax
you guys are not invited if you want to
see what we did in Venice
yesterday check out the video right next
to us I think you'll enjoy it continue
to believe now I'll see you there
you think I was gonna take a picture if
I was taking your picture I went a video
I think she's okay she has to come out
running screaming so I think we're good